hello movie clippers i'm sam and i'm
david and we're going to review a
million ways to die in the west uh seth
mcfarlane's new western comedy yeah so
dave what did you think of the movie
overall uh it reminded me a lot of
family guy as it should because it's
seth macfarlane and i love american dad
and family guy and i think the humor is
great in this movie uh it's pretty rare
to see a western comedy so in this movie
there's a lot of uh i guess you'd call
them basically like crude adult humor
jokes the same way family guy a lot of
penis jokes fart jokes stuff like that
so what it's exactly what you expect
from seth macfarlane so if you like
family guy you're not going to be
disappointed yeah it's it is very funny
and i i legitimately howled in the
theater while we were watching it it's
very funny the the thing is it doesn't
actually there's not like
you know the the judd apatow human thing
that leaves you you know with some
emotions when you go out of the theater
but it's just like a a straight up
really funny really filthy comedy i
didn't realize how far they were gonna
go with it and then they
they went further but uh i you know i
mean for both of us i think the
highlight would be the smuttyness of the
humor and the extent to which they push
it
uh you know i liked it i think it's kind
of interesting to to make a western
comedy when that genre
isn't really a genre anymore like what
were the last westerns you saw in
theaters i mean there's lone ranger and
lone ranger and lone ranger didn't do
that well in the box office nor was it a
comedy so i was surprised johnny depp
wasn't in this he seems to be in every
single western movie that's made in the
last 10 years yeah and so if you haven't
seen many westerns the jokes will still
work because most of the jokes are
making fun of the time period and not
sort of western tropes or anything like
that
like you're looking at a movie like
blazing saddles it's a little bit
different yeah blazing saddles much more
about westerns and this is much more
about saying filthy words yeah and
there's tumbleweeds
yeah the characters in this talk like
it's modern times it's almost like they
time travel to the west and they're
talking about it sort of saying like
isn't it ridiculous that no one smiles
and photographs and then like there's a
lot of humor sort of like a like a fish
out of water kind of moments like that
so there's not that many other western
comedies yeah out there i mean we got
blazing saddles maybe shanghai noon um
that's kind of it i mean back in the
future if you're really willing to
stretch it i mean it's back to the
future three and rango and rainbow so
that's from a couple this is definitely
i would say at the peak of the funniest
of like western colonies and you can
tell seth macfarlane really wanted to
dress up as a cowboy and that's totally
fine because he made it a good movie in
conclusion i guess if you're looking for
hilarious filthy western mustache humor
this is kind of the movie to go to right
now yeah uh so i think we both liked it
yeah it's it's very funny the jokes land
it's also very adventurous there's a
cool train chase sequence there's a lot
of horseback sequences and gun shooting
sequences no you're thinking of uh lone
ranger anyway for movie clips i'm sam
and i'm david thanks a lot